even if producers at the History Channel
knew they'd struck gold when they cast
the stars of mountain men they couldn't
have predicted just how rich the vein
they'd hit here are just a few tidbits
of trivia that never made it to
television screens all about the
toughest guys in the world Eustace
Conway's school beef inspired by Henry
David Thoreau Eustace Conway ran his
North carolina-based nature school on
his own property for over two decades
without incident but in February 2012
County officials claimed they discovered
some safety violations and shut it all
down the county government has issued
used as a cease and desist order telling
him to shut down his nature school
saying his buildings don't meet code
Conway and his staff were shocked at the
county sudden crackdown since he said
that the county's previous inspections
hadn't ever found any problems we'd
never had anybody hurt by one of the
buildings we've never had any health
issue here and so like after 26 years
that's a pretty strong statement he and
his staff didn't see how they could
comply with the new demands if we
complied to everything that the county
is requesting we would cease to exist
as we are it's just not an option Conway
thought he'd been wronged and took his
fight to the courts fortunately the
state stepped in and passed a law
providing an exemption for his school in
2013 not very neighborly about 10 months
in the Conway's dispute with the county
he got into a fight with his neighbor
Margaret a parms she told the high
country press that they were once good
friends until Conway disputed the
property line they'd shared for years
the argument reached a head in December
2012 and poms told the press he went and
tied our gate shut so we couldn't get
out and he put posters all over our
dates mailboxes fences then he put big
wooden barriers so we couldn't get out
he just kind of went nuts but Conway got
another good break in
a of the following year the high country
Press reported that the charges had been
dismissed Tom oars one-day audition
people who live off the land are
unfairly stereotyped as being a little
crazy but indeed some folks who decide
to go off the grid a gifted with more of
that special something that makes for
great reality TV take Tom oar for
example on the recommendation of oars
neighbor mountain man followed him
around for a day before they decided he
had to be on television of course they
didn't take into account some of the
things that they might have to endure
like follow him on a three-day hunting
expedition whilst carrying 25 pounds of
camera equipment if anyone was crazy in
this situation it might have been the
crew Hawes business boom unlike some
reality television personalities Tom oar
has adjusted pretty well to his newfound
fame selling moccasins custom knives and
other wilderness goodies mountain man's
all cleans up as viewers have started
clamoring for his goods if you're
interested in buying some of it however
we have bad news or doesn't have an
internet presence which means you have
to get your butt out to Yaak Montana if
you want some genuine merchandise if
he's not sold out that is Charlie
Tucker's house was a local attraction
before mountain men started Charlie
Tucker was already a local celebrity in
North Maine woods not only did everyone
in town know about the guy who built a
cabin with his own hands his house was
also one of two stops on a day-long tour
after taking the tour themselves
produces Soren Tucker a willpower and
stubbornness that told them he had to be
on their show protector of the people
years before he gained fame a mountain
man rich Lewis was already hailed as a
hero in Montana for his reputation for
mountain lion fighting in 2007 a
mountain lion ran amok in Twin Bridges
Montana killing two dogs had it been
left alone there's no telling what it
would have done
next fortunately the departments of Fish
Wildlife and Parks reached an agreement
with Lewis and set him loose on the
Cougar he took it out before it could
harm any other animals or worse
someone's child rich Lewis's dog
delivery in season four of mountain men
Lewis lost his best friend his dog
brandy bill Lane dantana and Lukas Simms
all fans of the show knew they needed to
do something so they bought him a new
canine companion to make this heartfelt
gesture
the trio journeyed 1,700 miles to
Lewis's off-the-grid homestead it's good
for local business when the History
Channel decided to send camera crews to
follow Lewis and ore through remote
areas of Montana they probably didn't
anticipate the good it would do rather
than send their own crews out into the
wild producers hired the local Warm
Springs Productions crew to film the
wilderness buffs by 2013 the company
employed roughly 70 people and needed to
move into a larger facility in addition
mountain men led to other gigs like
filming for the Travel Channel's making
monsters Marty meierotto lifesaver
because of the public's fascination with
these rugged outdoorsmen newspapers and
magazines have taken upon themselves to
find out more about them this isn't
always a good idea Field & Stream
magazine sent bill heavy to spend some
time with Marty meierotto
as the writer followed my rudder around
during an Alaskan winter for three days
he quickly discovered he was out of his
element at one point he V tried to make
it back to Marty's cabin on his own and
got lost
luckily my Arado knew what he was doing
and was able to save the reporter from
becoming a popsicle thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which mountain man fact surprised
you the most